hi this is Matt Welch from recent TV i'm
here at the Denver Performing Arts
Center with an ostrich who is making the
claim here today that McCain's head is
in the sand on the economy Thank You
ostrich for talking to us why is
McCain's a head in the sand on the
economy in your judgment well I think
he's going to just follow in bushes
footsteps and not care about the lower
middle class or even the middle class
for that matter any longer and not care
about this country and just prolong the
war and and continue putting all of the
money that I think should go back into
this country into the people of this
country instead of killing people for
starters I just for definitional reasons
what is the middle class to you what it
looks like some numbers well give it
like I don't know I suppose I don't know
between you being how much money they
make I don't know I guess I just what
does it mean to you the term middle
class well its people who just live kind
of they have they have one house
probably and then they which is one more
than I have Oh see there you go then and
they probably send their kids to public
schools and they I don't know I don't
know how to define it but you know
you're not making a hundred thousand
dollars a year it's under a thousand
hundred thousand dollars a year do you
think most of the Democratic speakers
we've seen so far send their kids to
public schools you know i'm not sure i
haven't actually gone into i've tried to
get into some things and like they
wouldn't let me in tell me briefly about
life as an ostrich is the local climate
hospitable yes very much that people
love this this guy yes he's very well
received and how is barack obama are
going to be different on the economy in
a way that the ostriches would find
copacetic I think for starters he came
from you know he worked hard to get to
where he was and he came from you know
not a wealthy family and he worked his
way and I think he's aware of the you
know of regular people and I think he'll
be aware of it and pay attention to
things that otherwise wouldn't get
attention well thank you very much this
ostrich this has been Matt Welch for
reason TV thank you